SO MUCH HAS HAPPENED OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC THAT IS
EASY TO FORGET HOW A YEAR AND
A HALF AGO,
NEW YORK CITY WAS THE WORST
HOTSPOT IN AMERICA. IT WAS ON
THIS EXACT DATE 18 MONTHS
AGO, THAT A HEALTH CARE WORKER
WHO LIVED IN MANHATTAN BECAME
THE
CITIES AND THE STATE'S FIRST
CONFIRMED CASE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS,
THE CITY AND ITS SURROUNDING
SUBURBS OVER 20 MILLION
PEOPLE
HAD FAR, MORE CASES THAN MANY
COUNTRIES HAD AT THE TIME
AND CERTAINLY, MORE THAN THE
REST OF THE NATION. THIS IS
WHAT THE U.S. LOOKED LIKE ON
APRIL, THE 15TH OF LAST YEAR
WITH NEW.
STATE OUTPACING THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY, MOST OF THOSE
CASES IN THE CITY OF NEW YORK.
NOW, LOOK AT HOW THE SITUATION
IS EVOLVED ACROSS THE US SINCE
THEN, IN THIS INTERACTIVE
MAP FROM OUR FRIENDS AT PBS
NEWSHOUR, AS CASES OF THE
CORONAVIRUS OF EXPLODED
AMONG THE UNVACCINATED,
PARTICULARLY IN THE
SOUTH BUT
TURNING BACK THE CLOCK IN NEW
YORK CITY, AT THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC,
REFRIGERATION TRUCKS WOULD BE
BROUGHT IN TO SERVE AS
MAKESHIFT MORGUES, A
CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATION, WOULD BUILD A
FIELD HOSPITAL IN
CENTRAL PARK.
AMONG THE DOG WALKERS ARE NOT
FAR FROM WHERE KIDS WOULD
STILL PLAY
TO HANDLE IT. OVERFLOW OF
PATIENT FROM MOUNT SINAI.
HOSPITAL
ACROSS FIFTH AVENUE, THE
MILITARY WOULD CONVERT THE
CITY'S MASSIVE
CONVENTION CENTER INTO ANOTHER
FIELD HOSPITAL. THE
NAVY WOULD SEND ITS HOSPITAL
SHIP TO DOCK IN THE HUDSON
RIVER AND EVERY NIGHT AT
7 P.M. THIS IS WHAT NEW YORK
CITY WOULD SOUND LIKE.
CHEERING
CLAPPING AND THE BANGING OF
POTS AND PANS AS NEW YORKERS
GATHERED AT THEIR WINDOWS TO
THANK HEALTH CARE WORKERS. IT
WAS THE SOUND OF HOPE
ALL THE, WHILE THE MAYOR BILL
DE BLASIO AND THEN GOVERNOR
ANDREW, CUOMO WERE UNDER FIRE
FOR THEIR INITIAL RESPONSE TO
THE CRISIS MUCH OF THE TIME.
THE TWO WERE FIGHTING ABOUT
THEIR COVID STRATEGIES WITH
EACH OTHER OVER WHEN TO SHUT
DOWN, AND WHAT TO SHUT DOWN
AND WHO HAD THE AUTHORITY TO
DO SO, AND HOW TO COMMUNICATE
AT ALL TO THE PUBLIC. BUT
THINGS IN NEW YORK, EVENTUALLY
GOT BETTER. IF NOT BETWEEN THE
MAYOR AND THE GOVERNOR
THINGS GOT BETTER REGARDING
THE CORONAVIRUS
CENTRAL PARK, WENT FROM
HOSTING A FIELD HOSPITAL
TO HOLDING A HOMECOMING.
CONCERT
NEW YORK'S VACCINATION. DRIVE
WAS PART OF THAT. AND YET WITH
THE DELTA VARIANT AND
SCHOOL STARTING AND COLDER
WEATHER JUST AROUND THE
CORNER. THERE ARE QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER IT WILL BE
ENOUGH
JOINING US. NOW, TO TALK ABOUT
ALL OF THIS IS THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CITY
THEN,
AND NOW BILL DE BLASIO
MR. MAYOR. THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING ME ON THE SHOW
TONIGHT. YOU'VE DONE A LOT
RECENTLY
TO
GET NEW.
BECAUSE VACCINATED EDUCATORS
HAVE TO BE VACCINATED
HEALTH CARE WORKERS
CITY EMPLOYEES, A HAVE TO BE
VACCINATED OR TESTED WEEKLY.
THERE ARE NEW VACCINE MANDATES
FOR RESTAURANTS OTHER PUBLIC
VENUES. I WELCOME ALL OF THAT.
I WISH
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS IN THE
SOUTH WERE DOING WHAT YOU'RE
DOING,
BUT I WONDER DO YOU HAVE
MORE PLANNED ON THE
VACCINATION FRONT? GIVEN THE
SCALE OF THE CHALLENGE? WHAT
ELSE CAN YOU DO TO GET NUMBERS
UP?
WELL, MARY, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
WE'VE HAD A VISION
OF FIGHTING BACK
AGGRESSIVELY WITH
$100 INCENTIVE FOR ANYONE WHO
COMES IN NEW TO GET
VACCINATED.
YES, SOMETHING
PRESIDENT BIDEN BOUGHT INTO
RIGHT AWAY AND
ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO DO ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY. THAT'S BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL. SO
I KEEP SAYING WE'RE CLIMBING A
LADDER
OF BOTH
INCENTIVES AND MANDATES
TO FIND MORE AND MORE WAYS
TO REACH PEOPLE, AND IT'S
HAVING A HUGE IMPACT.
THE VACCINATION NUMBERS ARE
GOING UP
MARKEDLY
AND MANY
THERE, PARTICULARLY GOING UP
AMONGST
BLACK LUNG.
TINO, NEW YORKERS.
AND WE ARE LITERALLY AT THIS
POINT WILLING TO GO TO
PEOPLE'S HOMES. WE WILL SEND
VACCINATORS TO YOUR
HOME'S, TO BE ABLE TO GIVE YOU
IN PERSON VACCINATION FOR YOUR
WHOLE FAMILY AND EACH.
REMEMBER GETS $100 INCENTIVE
WHO'S ELIGIBLE TO BE
BACK SAYING, THIS IS A VERY
HANDS-ON
GRASSROOTS EFFORT.
IT'S MAKING A HUGE IMPACT AND
PEOPLE ARE REALLY COPYING. A
LOT OF THE THINGS WE'RE DOING
HERE.
THERE'S A
POWERFUL
POLL THAT THE HILL JUST CAME
OUT WITH ALMOST A THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS
MAKING CLEAR THAT ABOUT HALF
OF THEM ALREADY. ARE PUTTING
VACCINE MANDATES, HAVE
DIFFERENT KINDS IN PLACE WHEN
THE NATION'S LARGEST CITY
MOVES, IT HELPS PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR MOVE AROUND THE
COUNTRY. THAT WAS PART OF WHAT
WE
HOPE TO DO, AND
WE'RE REALLY SEEING THE
IMPACT NOW.
SO WHAT'S NEXT, WHAT MORE CAN
BE DONE TO GET THOSE NUMBERS
ARE, IS IT A MATTER OF PAYING
PEOPLE MORE, GIVING MORE MONEY
OUT? I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT A RANGE OF OPTIONS
INCLUDING,
OF COURSE, THE POTENTIAL FOR
ADDITIONAL
MANDATES. WE HAVE A SENSE.
I CERTAINLY BELIEVE IN
SEQUENCING RIGHT NOW. THE
FOCUS IS ON BRINGING SCHOOL
BACCHUS JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AWAY. THAT'S A VERY STRONG
MANDATE. WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WORKS,
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT A VARIETY
OF OTHER OPTIONS,
BUT ALSO THE INCENTIVE FRONT
IS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
NOTE, THE
$100 INCENTIVE HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE. WE
HAVE A NEW INCENTIVE. WE'VE
JUST STARTED
WITH PHYSICIANS.
WE FINALLY GOT SOME FEDERAL
SUPPORT FOR THIS
TO LITERALLY PROVIDE EXTRA
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
PHYSICIANS IF THEY
SYSTEMATICALLY
REACH OUT TO THEIR PATIENTS
TO TALK ABOUT
VACCINATIONS TO ENCOURAGE IT
TO DEMYSTIFY IT, TO
HELP PEOPLE MAKE APPOINTMENTS,
WE WANT TO REWARD
INDIVIDUAL PHYSICIANS WHO
LITERALLY TAKE A LIST OF ALL
THEIR PATIENTS
PATIENTS AND
WORK ALL THE WAY THROUGH IT
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
TRUSTED VOICES IN ANYONE'S
LIFE.
INTERESTING. AND, BUT IT
HASN'T BEEN ORGANIZED AS SUCH
AND THAT HASN'T BEEN THE KIND
OF
RESOURCE INCENTIVE THAT WOULD
HELP. WE'VE NOW PUT THOSE
PIECES TOGETHER. 35 MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM HERE IN THE
CITY THAT I THINK IS GOING TO
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
WE CAN ONLY HOPE
MR. MAYOR. I ALSO SAW THAT
REGARDING RESTAURANTS IN YOUR
CITY. YOU ANNOUNCED
AT PEYTON'S, PATRONS, WILL BE
ALLOWED TO DINE AS SOON AS
THEY GET
THEIR FIRST COVID SHOT,
LITERALLY AS SOON AS YOU'VE
GOT THE SHOT, YOU SAID, WHICH
IS A NICE SENTIMENT,
BUT IT MAKES NO SCIENTIFIC
SENSE. DOES IT GIVEN YOU DON'T
GET IMMUNITY FROM THE VIRUS
STRAIGHT AFTER THE SHOT?
ESPECIALLY THE FIRST SHOT? IT
TAKES A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
IT MAKES STRATEGIC SENSE. AND
THIS IS WHY OUR
HEALTH CARE LEADERS HAVE
REALLY BOUGHT INTO THIS IDEA
BECAUSE IT'S AN INCENTIVE
TO GET MORE.
PEOPLE VACCINATED, LOOK
MADDY, THE WHOLE IDEA WAS
VACCINATION. YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT ANY OTHER TOOLS ANY
OTHER PIECES OF THE EQUATION,
BUT WE DECIDED HERE
HAVING BEEN THE EPICENTER AS
YOU POWERFULLY LAID OUT
EARLIER.
WE DECIDED THERE'S ONE
STRATEGY.
IT'S VACCINATION GAIN TO THE
MOST PERVASIVE LEVEL OF
VACCINATION POSSIBLE. NOW, I'M
HAPPY TO TELL YOU
77 PERCENT OF ADULTS IN NEW
YORK CITY RIGHT NOW, HAVE
GOTTEN AT LEAST ONE DOSE
AND ALMOST EVERYONE WHO GETS
THE FIRST DOSE COMES BACK FOR
THE SECOND. SO THE STRATEGIC
IDEA THERE WAS
LET'S
SAY THAT PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
MORE
HESITANT
LESS ENGAGING IN THE VACCINE.
YOU WANT TO ENJOY LIFE IN NEW
YORK CITY. IT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS YOUNG PEOPLE FLOCK HERE
TO DO THE RESTAURANTS
THE BARS, THE CONCERTS
YOU WANT, ALL THAT.
YOU HAVE TO BE VACCINATED,
BUT WE'RE NOT TELLING YOU, YOU
HAVE TO WAIT
A MONTH OR SIX WEEKS. WE'RE
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO JUST
GET STARTED IMMEDIATELY. EVEN
THE FIRST DOSE.
AND FIRST SOME PROTECTION, WE
KNOW THAT SCIENTIFICALLY,
BUT THIS IS STRATEGIC. WELL,
THIS IS ABOUT CONDUCTING,
THE MESSAGE.
REPUBLICAN VOTER PROTECTION
IMMEDIATELY DONE.
IT DOESN'T GO
FURTHER FLEXIBILITY, BUT I
TAKE YOUR POINT ABOUT
INCENTIVES.
IT CONFERS PROTECTION, BUT
OUR POINT IS A STRATEGIC ONE.
IF SOMEONE GETS VACCINATED FOR
THE FIRST TIME,
JUSTIN, THEY ARE ON THE
PATHWAY TO GETTING VACCINATED
TOTALLY AND THAT AND AS YOU
PLENTY OF OTHER, THAT'S A GOOD
SAFETY MEASURES ON TOP OF
THAT. LET'S BE CLEAR,
INCLUDING IN OUR
RESTAURANTS, BUT THE KEY IS
GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED. YOU GOT TO GET HIM
STARTED.
AGREED
MR.
MATTHEW VAUGHN PULLED ITS FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON COVID ON
VACCINATIONS THIS YEAR. AS YOU
SAID, YOU'VE LED THE WAY ON
SOME OF THE MANDATE POLICIES,
BUT LOOKING BACK ON THAT
AWFUL PERIOD IN
NEW YORK'S HISTORY.
STARTED THE PANDEMIC, THE
SPRING OF
2020, YOUR CRITICS AS, YOU
KNOW, SAY YOU
MISHANDLED THE SITUATION. YOU
DIDN'T TAKE THE PANDEMIC
SERIOUSLY ENOUGH, EARLY
ENOUGH. I WANT TO PLAY A BIT
OF SOUND AND GET YOUR REACTION
ON THE OTHER SIDE. HAVE A
A LISTEN.
LOOK, WE'RE ALSO TELLING
PEOPLE TO NOT AVOID.
RESTAURANTS, NOT AVOID.
YOU KNOW, THE NORMAL
THINGS THAT WOULD DO
IT. THIS DOES NOT
TRANSMITTED THROUGH FOOD OR
DRINK. SO PEOPLE
SHOULD GO OUT AND CONTINUE
TO LIVE. LIFE SHOULD GO OUT TO
RESTAURANTS.
IN HINDSIGHT
SAYING, CARRY ON WITH LIFE, AS
NORMAL ON MARCH, THE 11TH.
THAT WAS THE DAY. THE,
WHO OFFICIALLY DECLARED A
PANDEMIC. THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
WE CAN ALL AGREE RIGHT NOW.
CAN'T WE? WELL, BASED ON
WHAT WE KNOW NOW, OF COURSE,
BUT THAT'S NOT THE POINT. THE
POINT IS, WE NEED THE
INFORMATION. WE HAD THE TIME
AT THE TIME. WE HAD
EVIDENCE OF A SMALL NUMBER OF
CASES.
WE DID NOT KNOW UNTIL MUCH
LATER HOW PERVASIVE THE
DISEASE ALREADY HAVE BECOME
EVEN IN FEBRUARY
AND I WAS LISTENIN
F
COURSE
COURSE TO MY HEALTH.
SHIP. AND THE GOAL WAS TO
NOT SAY TO PEOPLE
THAT WE HAD REACHED A POINT
FOR SHUTTING DOWN OUR SOCIETY,
BUT TRYING TO STRIKE A BALANCE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE CASES
WE HAD
AND GET PEOPLE TO DO THE
PRECAUTIONS THAT ARE
HEALTH TEAM WERE IMPORTANT
THOUGHT WERE IMPORTANT AT A
TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY, WITHIN A FEW
DAYS IT BECAME CLEAR. WE
WERE IN A WHOLE DIFFERENT
SITUATION
AND THAT'S WHEN I STARTED
CALLING FOR SHELTER IN PLACE.
AND YOU ACCURATELY PORTRAYED
THAT UNFORTUNATELY, I HAD TO
FIGHT WITH OUR STATE'S
GOVERNOR, BUT THAT'S WHAT WE
NEEDED TO DO.
THE MOMENT IT.
HAS CLEAR TO ME, WE NEEDED TO
HAVE SHELTER IN PLACE IF WE
HAD IMPLEMENTED THAT RIGHT,
THEN.
IF NEW YORK CITY HAD HAD THAT
POWER, THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE DIFFERENCE MAKER
AND I ONLY WISH WE HAD HAD A
VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION THAN
THAT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED ME TO
DO
THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE AT THE TIME
SAID, THE RIVALRY BETWEEN YOU
AND THEN GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO,
COST, NEW YORKERS LIVES. DO
YOU ACCEPT THAT? EVEN IF YOU
PUT THE BLAME ON HIM, NOT
YOURSELF. OR DO YOU ACCEPT THE
POLITICS OF THAT TIME
DEFINITELY DID COST RIGHT? YOU
KNOW, I DON'T THINK IT'S
PRODUCTIVE
TO
RE-LITIGATE. I THINK WHAT'S
CLEAR IS
AND I WANT TO BE FAIR, EVEN
TO ANDREW CUOMO YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT'S A TOUGH
STATEMENT FOR ME TO SAY
IN THE END IS A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
WE HAD NO NATIONAL LEADERSHIP.
WE DID NOT HAVE TESTING,
WE HAD
MISINFORMATION.
COMING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE WERE DEALING WITH THE GREAT
UNKNOWN. EVEN OUR BEST,
SCIENTISTS AND HEALTHCARE
LEADERS HERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
ONLY HAD VERY INITIAL
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE DISEASE.
WE HAVE TO PUT ALL THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
WE CAN DO A LOT OF
MONDAY-MORNING QUARTERBACK,
BUT I THINK WHAT'S CLEAR. NOW,
WHAT'S CLEAR NOW, IS
THAT ONCE IT BECAME CLEAR
THE DETAILS AND THE FACTS WE
HAD TO BE VERY AGGRESSIVE.
AND
HE RAN AROUND THE COUNTRY. THE
ANSWER WAS TO DO THINGS LIKE
SHELTER IN PLACE. WE FINALLY
GOT THERE
BUT
BUT NOW WE HAVE A
A SITUATION THAT SO MUCH
CLEARER AND THAT'S WHAT'S
SHOCKING THAT AROUND THE
COUNTRY. THERE ISN'T A
DEVOTION OF VACCINATION. WE'RE
A HUNDRED PERCENT DEVOTED TO
IT. AND THAT'S WHY NEW YORK
CITY ACTUALLY
IS GOING BACK AND LIVING THE
LIFE WERE LIVING RIGHT
NOW.
UNDENIABLY TRUE.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT ANDREW
CUOMO, THOUGH. FORMER GOVERNOR
DID YOU KNOW,
HAD YOU HEARD RUMORS ABOUT
ANDREW CUOMO AND HIS ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT AROUND WOMEN
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN NEW
YORK SAY THIS WAS KNOWN
AND IT WAS KIND OF JUST PEOPLE
TURNED A BLIND EYE.
WELL, I WAS FOCUSED ON
HIS MISCONDUCT WHEN I CAME TO
NURSING HOMES,
WHICH WAS PROFOUNDLY
DAMAGING
OBVIOUSLY WE SAW,
THERE WAS
MISCONDUCT.
AROUND THE
DISTRIBUTION
OF
TESTING AND
VACCINATIONS AND POLITICAL
FAVORITISM THERE THAT I WAS
HONESTLY
FOCUSED ON THE CONTEXT OF
COVID. AND THE DAMAGE THAT WAS
BEING DONE.
WHEN WE STARTED TO HEAR THE
INDIVIDUAL STORIES. THEY WERE
TERRIFYING THAT THESE WOMEN
HAD BEEN PUT THROUGH THIS.
AND I GIVE ALL THE CREDIT
IN THE WORLD, TO THE WOMEN WHO
CAME FORWARD TO TAKING
AN IMMENSE RISK.
BECAUSE THEY FINALLY SHOCKED A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS STATE
WHO HAD LOOKED THE OTHER WAY
ON ANDREW
CUOMO, IN TO
EXACTLY WHO HE WAS?
AND I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOUR
FOCUS WAS, BUT
I'M GONNA ASK AGAIN BECAUSE
YOU DIDN'T QUITE ANSWER. THE
QUESTION. YOU WERE UNAWARE OF
ANY OF THOSE WOMEN STORIES
BEFORE THEY CAME FORWARD. YOU
HAD NO IDEA
OF THE SPECIFIC STORIES. NO,
OF COURSE, NOT.
ANYONE WHO WAS SHOULD HAVE
COME FORWARD WITH THEM. I
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THOSE BUT I
WAS DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
A HOST OF OTHER PROBLEMS AND
THEY'VE ALL, THEY'RE ALL TRUE.
THIS IS THE, THIS IS REALITY,
MANY, ALL THESE THINGS.
ALL THESE MISTAKES, ALL THESE
SINS, ALL THESE
HORRIBLE ACTIONS.
HAPPEN SIMULTANEOUSLY
AND THEIR OWN.
NOW, JUST BEGINNING TO BE
UNPACKED AND I'LL TELL YOU THE
INVESTIGATORS AND THE
PROSECUTORS HAVE A LOT TO WORK
WITH AND YOU CAN EXPECT A LOT
MORE CHAPTERS IN THIS STORY.
YOU'VE SAID, ANDREW CUOMO IS A
TYRANT. YOU SAID THAT HE
SHOULD BE CRIMINALLY CHARGED.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT HE WILL BE
SOME OF SOME? I'D SAY,
AMERICANS TEND NOT TO PUT SUCH
POWERFUL PEOPLE BEHIND BARS.
BARS.
I THINK THERE'S A MIXED BAG
AND THAT AREA, BUT IN NEW
YORK STATE WHICH CERTAINLY
SEEN A LOT OF POWERFUL PEOPLE
GO TO JAIL WHO RICHLY
DESERVE TO, THERE'S A NUMBER
OF PLACES WHERE HE MAY BE
PROSECUTED. SO I DON'T RULE IT
OUT AT ALL.
ONE LAST QUESTION MR. MAYOR.
THE NEXT MAYOR OF NEW YORK. IF
IT'S A DEMOCRAT, WILL BE ERIC
ADAMS, FORMER POLICE OFFICER
FORMER REPUBLICAN. YOU'VE
ENDORSED HIM,
HE AND MANY AROUND HIM SAY
HIS VICTORY IN THE PRIMARIES
WAS A VICTORY FOR MODERATES
AND A REJECTION OF WOKE
PROGRESSIVES. HOW DOES THAT
MAKE YOU FEEL AS A
SELF-PROFESSED PROGRESSIVE
MAYOR?
WAS HIS WINNIE DEFEAT FOR THE
LEFT OF YOUR PARTY, WHICH YOU
HAVE LONG IDENTIFIED WITH.
YEAH. I DON'T ACCEPT THE
ANALYSIS.
ERIC ADAMS
WAS
A PROFOUND.
ACT.
BEST
FIGHTING AGAINST
IMPROPER, POLICE
PRACTICES FROM WITHIN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
DOING EXTRAORDINARY WORK ON
CIVIL RIGHTS
DECADES AGO.
HE IS A WORKING-CLASS GUY
FROM BROOKLYN WHO REPRESENTS
THE INTERESTS OF WORKING
PEOPLE.
I'VE WORKED WITH THEM VERY
CLOSELY AND A LOT OF THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE
INITIATIVES OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION. I DON'T ACCEPT
THAT SIMPLIFICATION. I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
CONTINUITY
WITH A LOT OF THE PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES THAT WE
CREATED OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS.
I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
ALTHOUGH SOME OF THAT ANALYSIS
COMES FROM HIM AND PEOPLE
AROUND HIM NOT FROM ME. BUT
MAYOR BILL DE BLASIO. I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING TIME OUT
AND TAKING MY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU.